when the stakes are this high
doesn't make more sense to hear our
story from us keeping up with the
sussexes Harry obviously has a deal with
Netflix and he's in bed with Netflix
because he's got a Tokyo series coming
out well the first trailer for Prince
Harry and Meghan markle's upcoming
Netflix docu-series Harry and Megan just
dropped and shows a side of the couple
we've never seen before no one sees
what's happening behind the closed doors
I asked you everything I could to
protect my family that's the mom of two
wiping tears from her eyes why did you
want to make this documentary the
six-part donkey series will show Harry
and Megan's side of their high profile
love story and we'll explore the
clandestine days of their early
courtship and the challenges that led to
them feeling forced to step back from
their full-time roles in the institution
he is incredibly protective of Megan and
Archie in fact sources close to Harry
have told me that his greatest fear has
always been losing the person that he
loves the most because of the unique
position that he's in the doc's release
date has yet to be announced but based
on what's in the trailer we'll see the
couple's private moments and never
before seen photos the series will
feature commentary from friends and
family as well as historians who discuss
the state of the British Commonwealth
today and the Royal Family's
relationship with the Press plus the
series promises to show more than just
Harry and Meg's Love Story it'll also
paint a picture of our world and how we
treat each other
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex signed a
multi-million dollar production deal
with Netflix in September 2020 and Harry
he's also making a pretty penny for his
Memoir Harry has taken a 35 million
Advance the chances of him handing that
back and saying actually I'm not going
to do this book after all I think that's
highly unlikely when you're having that
sort of an advance that's not going to
be for Harry talking about his
philanthropic work that's going to be
the inside story of being born the spare
what it entailed I mean I've sat down
with with Harry before and he said to me
you know there are many times I wish I
wasn't born a prince it was very
apparent to me early on that he actually
wanted a way out the book titled spare
will be released on January 10th we're
told the royal family is a bit nervous
about it and I think the greatest threat
and the greatest concern certainly for
the Royals is the force coming
autobiography which is of course caused
a lot of consternation in Royal circles
a lot of concern amongst senior Royal
sources and Palisades because quite
simply they don't know what to expect
[Music]